مساء الخير مذبحه اورلاندو على يد المسلم
عمر متين لم تكن الاولى طبعا في السنوات
الاخيره ولن تكون الاخيره هناك عدد كبير
من الحوادث قولتكم مؤخرا في عدد كبير من
العواصم الغربيه وبينهم قاسم مشترك القاسم
المشترك دول ان هم مسلمين لكنهم ليسوا
عربا هم مسلمون جاؤوا من الجيل الثاني
والثالث من مسلمين استقروا في العواصم
الغربيه وبالتالي هذه الحوادث الارهابيه
ارتكبها ارهابيون غربيون هم مسلمون صحيح
لكنهم ليسوا عرب هذه الواقعه والوقائع
السابقه المماثله زي مثلا مذبحه
كاليفورنيا اللي قتل فيها مسلم من اصل
باكستاني وزوجته 14 امريكيا وقبلها حوادث
كثيره زي مذبحه فرنسا في نوفمبر الماضي
اللي راح ضحيتها حوالي 130 هم الفرنسيون
وبلجيكي ولدوا في الغرب وليسوا عربا
الحقيقه انه الحقائق دي ايقظت مره اخرى
الاسلام او جعلت من الغرب يعيد النظر مره
اخرى بعد فتره هدوء قصيره يعيد النظر
للاسلام باعتباره العدو الاكبر والتهديد
الاكبر للغرب وبيعتبر انه زي ما الغرب قاد
حملات صليبيه على الشرق المسلم سنه من سنه
1300 فالمسلمين دلوقتي بينظموا حملات
تشابه الحملات الصليبيه لاحتلال الغرب
واختراقه لكن ليس من خلال الجيوش ولكن من
خلال الهجرات المنتظمه الغرب بيبص
للمسلمين او بينظر لهم بقلق شديد
لاعتبارين اساسيين مش كل الناس واخدين
بالهم من هذه الاعتبارات الاعتبارات
الاعتبار الاول والخطير جدا انه في تغير
ديموغرافي بيثير قلق الغرب ديموغرافي يعني
سكاني التغير الديموغرافي ده في تركيبه
البنيه الغربيه بيميل بشده لصالح المسلمين
يعني التركيبه السكانيه لكثير من دول
الغرب لصالح المسلمين وبشكل واضح و بشكل
واضح وبيز بشكل كبير مع الزمن مركز بيو
المتخصص في الاحصاء والارقام عمل دراسه
مهمه جدا وقال فيها ان المسلمين هم
الديانه
الاكثر زياده في السكان من اي ديانه اخرى
في العالم واد مثل قال المسلمين في سنه
2010 كانوا 1 و5 من 1.6 من اسف مليار نسمه
1. 6 بيتوقع ان هم يكونوا في سنه
2.8 مليار نسمه يعني الديانه الاكثر في
العالم اللي كانت بتمثل 23% في 2010 سوف
تمثل 30% من اجمالي سكان العالم القصه مش
بس كده القصه كمان تتعلق بوضع المسلمين في
دول اوروبا يعني بيتوقع ان المسلمين اللي
بيمثلوا 6% دلوقتي من سكان اوروبا هيزاوا
هناك انا بتكلم عن المسلمين مش العرب اذا
كانوا مسيحيين او يهودا او من اي ديانه
اخرى العرب المسلمين من كل الاجناس اللي
موجودين في اوروبا هيزاوا من وضعهم القائم
الان اللي هو 6% من كل سكان اوروبا
هيزيد عفوا بنسبه
63% عشان يمثلوا 10% من سكان
اوروبا
نسبه الزياده عند كل الاديان الاخرى في
الوقت الحالي بيتكلموا على واحد وواد من ع
بينما بتوصل النسبه دي ل 1.8 من بين
السيدات المسلمات وبيرجعوا الكلام ده
لاسباب كتيره تتعلق ب انه في نسبه كبيره
جدا من الشباب في التركيبه المسلمين اللي
قادمين بلدان مختلفه نسبه الخصوبه العاليه
كمان ثقافه المسلمين اللي بتحب الانجاب في
مقابل بلدان اوروبيه بتعاني بشده من خطر
التناقص السكاني اللي بيدفع دول ومنها
المانيه على تشجيع المواليد لانها بتخش
بحلول سنه 2030
و250 من تناقص خطير جدا في سكانهم بعض
الناس بيتوقع ان الرجل الابيض بصفه عامه
هيكون اقليه في اي بلد من بلدان العالم كل
الكلام ده بيقول ان
المسلمين وكثرتهم بتهدد ثقافه وتركيبه هذه
الدول انا هقول لكم على مثل اكثر خطوره
بلد زي روسيا الناس الغرب لما بيراقب
روسيا مش قلان من سلاحها النووي ولا من
سياستها اللي هي دايما طبعا بتهدد استقرار
الغرب ولا من دعمها لدول زي مثلا ايران لا
ده هم عندهم كمان بالاضافه لكل خلافاتهم
السياسيه والعسكريه مع موسكو عنده مشكله
ثانيه كبيره جدا ان موسكو بتتحول تدريجيا
الى بلد الاغلبيه فيها للمسلمين المسلمين
بيمثلوا من ال 140 مليون نسمه اللي
موجودين في روسيا حوالي 23 مليون يعني اكث
من 15% من سكان روسيا لكن مره ثانيه معدل
المواليد عند الروسيات من غير المسلمات
1.1 من فيما ان معدل الخصوبه عند السيدات
المسلمات روسيات اين و3 من ففي فرق كبير
اضف انه السكان الروس لهم تركيبه غريبه
جدا باستثناء المسلمين عندهم معدلات
المواليد الاوروبيين اللي هي منخفضه جدا
ومعدلات وفيات الافرقه العاليه جدا نتيجه
ادمان الكحوليات ويعني العادات الصحيه
السيئه لكن ده ما ينطبق على
المسلمين حتى الجيش الجيش الروسي اللي هو
له ما له يعني من قوه ومن خطر خلال سنوات
قليله سوف يتجاوز عدد المسلمين فيه اكثر
من نصف العدد الجيش الروسي هيكون مكون من
مسلمين في واحد اسمه بول جلوب مهتم جدا
دارس بيدرس التركيبه السكانيه الروسيه قال
كلمه خطيره قال ان روسيا بتمر بمرحله تغير
ديني يعني الانتقا طبعا بيتكلم على انها
تتحول الى بلد مسلمه وتوابع هذا التغير
سوف يكون له اثر اكبر بكثير على المجتمع
العالمي او على العالم من انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي فحضروا هذا التغير كل اللي انا
بقوله ده وكل الارقام اللي انا بقولها دي
بتصب فيه نقدر نلخصها في جمله او جملتين
المسلمين بياخذوا اوروبا رغما عن اوروبا
بشكل يصعب ايقافه لانه في عمليه تكاثر
بالمناسبه اسم محمد احمد وفاطمه من اكثر
الاسماء انتشارا في العواصم الغربيه
ومشاهد الاماكن اللي بيصلي فيها المسلمين
في مداخل المحلات ومداخل البيوت مشاهد
مالوفه وصناعه الحلال صناعه بقت بزنس مربح
في كثير من دول اوروبا عاوز اقوله انه
اوروبا تشعر بقلق شديد العالم الغربي بصفه
عامه لكن خصوصا اوروبا بيشعر بقلق شديد
نتيجه التحول التدريجي في باتجاه المسلمين
كل ده كان ممكن قبوله لو ان الاغلبيه او
هذه الاقليه اللي بتزداد تدريجيا كانت اي
اقليه اخرى خلاف المسلمين يعني اقليات سي
مثلا من البلدان
الافريقيه او من بعض الديانه الهندوسيه او
المسيحيه اللي جايين من دول اسيويه دول
ناس عاوزين حياه افضل وعندهم استعداد ان
هم يندمجوا في الحياه الغربيه هذا اثبت
التجربه انه لا ينطبق على كثير من
المسلمين اللي عاوزين يروحوا يعيشوا حياه
افضل في الغرب لكنهم يحتقرونه ويسعون اولا
لعدم الاندماج فيه بسبب الخلافات الثقافيه
والدينيه لكن ممكن كمان اخطر ان بعضهم زي
عمر متين وغيره بيسعى بقوه الى تغيير
هؤلاء الغربيين وفرض نمط حياه عليهم زي ما
رفض مثلا وضع ان يكون في نادي ليلي متخص
صص لاستقبال الشواز فاطلق نيرانه عليهم
الحقيقه سالت شخص في مستشرق هولندي معروف
يعني في دوائر المستشرقين اسمه هانس يانسن
وكنت اجريت معاه اكثر من حوار وهو واخد
طبعا موقف الى حد كبير يعتبر معادي لل
نقول للاسلاميين مش
للمسلمين انه كيف ترى يعني انه في نمو
الاسلاموفوبيا او الخوف الشديد من
المسلمين فته على سؤالي وقال لي ان
الاسلاموفوبيا ده في عقولكم انتم ما فيش
اسلاموفوبيا في خطر حقيقي موجود علينا لكن
انتم بتقلل منه وبتعتمد مجرد مؤامره او
خوف مبالغ فيه واداني امثله كثيره جدا من
عدد كتير من المسلمين المستقرين في بلدان
الغرب اللي قتلوا مواطنيهم لانهم بيرفضو
نمط الحياه عليه واداني مثل بمسلم موجود
في هولندا من كام سنه وقف في مدخل المتحف
ال القومي الهولندي وهو بيسب الناس ويتهدم
ويتوعدهم وبيقول لهم ان انتم اشر من
الدواب يبدو ان دوت في اشاره للايه
الكريمه اللي بتقول هم كالانعام بل اضل
سبيلا بالمناسبه هانس يانسن بيعرف عربي
معقول وبيقول لي ان الراجل ده اللي جاه
واستفاد سواء هو او الجيل اللي قبله من كل
الامتيازات في الحياه الغربيه بيقابل هذا
مش بس بنوع من الشكر والعرفان او حتى قبول
الاختلاف مع الناس اللي موجوده او الدعوه
لدينه بالموعظه الحسنه لا ده عاوز يغير
بالسلاح وبالسكين لكل هذه الاسباب يشعر
الغرب بعجز شديد وبضيق شديد تجاه الاسلام
بالمناسبه يعني انا بختلف مع الناس اللي
بيعتقدوا ان الغرب بيكره المسلمين هو
بيشعر بتهديد اليهم ولا يكره المسلمين هو
يرغب في استغلال المسلمين زي ما يرغب في
استغلال اي اصحاب ديانه اخرى يرغب في
استغلال المسلمين لانه يرغب في استغلال
الجميع وامتصاص ثرواتهم لكنه لا يعادل
المسلمين كمسلمين هو فقط يشعر بالقلق منهم
للاسباب التي اشرت اليها الغزو السكاني
الهائل اللي بيزداد مع الهجره اللي باتت
تمثل دلوقتي هاجس لدى كل صناع القرار في
الغرب وبيحطوا اليه الامر الثاني هو
المسلمين لنمط الحياه الغربيه ورغبتهم في
تغيير هذا النمط بالقوه اشكركم والى لقاء
اخر ان شاء الله